[Music]
not like that was handed to her she made
her own money for over a decade there
was hard work put into something Kim
Kardashian and Kris and Kendall Jenner
want you to know Kylie is a self-made
businesswoman I'm Kylie Jenner and I am
the founder of Kylie cosmetics earlier
this month forbes revealed Kylie's
empire is worth nine hundred million
dollars
they say she's set to become the
youngest ever self-made billionaire I
put so much love into everything that I
make and I make sure everything is
perfect and something I would personally
use is she got a little backlash people
said not self-made what did you guys
feel as a family seeing her kind of have
to deal with that and how do you feel
about the word self-made because she's
worked so hard yeah I feel like to me
self-made is when you know everyone has
a team I don't care who you are how you
know but when you don't get it from
someone else
that's self-made so it's not like that
was handed to her she figured that all
out I mean we all have I look at it like
this she made her own money for over a
decade she put it in the bank
she saved every nickel and then when she
decided she really you know decided on
what she wanted to do she spent her
money on a venture that could have gone
south or north and it did really well so
I think that takes away from the fact
that there was hard work put into
something I think that I think that you
that doesn't just happen if you're if
you're
doing something about it you're just
sitting at home being lazy I don't think
that could happen no yeah I think it
says something about just working the
famous family is all about hard work and
giving back
et spoke with them at the forum for City
of Hope's if only Texas Hold'em
charity poker tournament how's your
poker face how you gonna be in there you
know I think my I laugh a lot it's just
my kind of nervous laugh I could have a
really good hand I could have a really
bad hand but I've never played before
the whole family no one's played before
but I swear I'm really good the research
that they do for cancer research and
various diseases including diabetes is
important to me and in our family
because that we had several family
members that have had a brush with
various things but I think that more
importantly they provide treatment for
people who can't afford it and it's free
and that to me was really you know was
what attracted me I think it's important
to keep raising money for this amazing
organization because there's so many
people that are affected by the care
that they bring
[Music]
[Applause]